hello and welcome to this video
shellfish is the opponent South f South
Africa and its mix it up some other
opening Trump yeah not really knowing
anything goes back maybe d5 now I'm kind
of it I really don't know the move all
the subtleties here night h5 okay yeah
probably all the way back ah ok tweenage
form you can probably take now you play
Knight f6 and then d5
yeah it wasn't a good opening what the
beep did I do wrong we should see one
may be in at the end yeah this is like
one of the worst opening positions after
10 moves that I had in recent times Wow
completely idiotic f3 move in this
position and I'm down development wise
it's not good and get this very very um
very bad okay maybe ok it's a good move
I absolutely hate this position
I can actually just take on it for then
and win apiece Wow
how do I get some position that I can at
least play and that happens when you
experiment there with stuff that you
have no idea about it can work out well
if the other guy play some some non some
non-critical stuff but if they don't you
end up with a rotten position like that
with white
maybe I'm managing at least to get
castles that would be really good
I was thinking about the same that's a
very aggressive try I'm I do not sure
about it Bishop g3n don't think works I
can take f9f to at the end yeah that's
definitely more interesting so but what
if I go King f2 now here let's do it
okay it's covering this is threatening
night be five yeah this isn't all that
bad anymore just wonder how to how to do
it him I entered this in trying to make
the H porn 90 come on Gigi three ah
never play early in the morning or
whatever I mean no come on how can i do
that what a waste and the position i
think was not that bad all of a sudden
okay mean it's still not like the
easiest ever okay first of all if i can
go does he have a winner
we should be five horse what I'm trying
to evaluate root chief I'd is of course
the thing I hope she ate I'm sorry yeah
played instantly so he has discovered
attacks time morning I got already time
warning things things get better and
better
funny thing is I can absolutely not move
the King away what a rotten game and now
at least age 4 + f6 are hanging
h5 is hanging
check check check what he went back okay
Liz I didn't blunder blunders stuff
right away which could have happened
check it's irritating move on no check
yes you're great check great stuff check
one more year check check check check
check check check mate yeah okay well
that was an up and down game yeah so I I
mean I actually deserve to lose right
for the opening that was so terrible I
mean this is this must be I think
somewhat normal when he went with this
yeah probably bishop see one is bad I
just don't have the time for that move
but where do I go the engine gets Bishop
e3 it's not exactly natural looking
I know that this is a move and this is
an option but it shouldn't be the only
one yeah anyway I this this is just bad
yeah black has a very nice Harmon yeah
very nice ammonia's position and my my
night is bad and so on yeah he took
which is think strong directly playing
for for an attack in the center they had
a hard time to keep keep the game going
g5 now this and this is a mistake 96-94
swinging for for him quite to the
computer and it's all surprised I said
this the opening play was really bad
yeah engine still loves black yeah of
course h4 is just an unbelievable move
check a knight h5 seems to win now which
I mean they they all win somehow Queen
d7 still winning it also still wins
after that I'm winning but um I'm just
seen so I'm not not quite yet awake I
don't understand what's the problem is
here rook g1 is the problem oh ok here I
was thinking I would win but this is
check leading to made apparently check
check check yeah computer front so Jack
long move may check check check and so
on where do I get made it which I'll
chat with chicken clucks phone books
phone check checking key made check
check check check check mate ok so if he
takes that finds roop chi 1 i'm
completely toast now the other way
around check check check yeah of course
I should just take on g8 but somehow I
was irritated him check yeah I now
Bishop c4 is the only thing quite clear
Liam 15 seconds okay i can go gauge aid
or whatever check our queen bee three
when i was to pierce them the check
check blundering the whole Queen check
when you blundered the roof
back and whatever yet those 10 seconds
each at the end is never going to be
very much heavier logics okay thanks for
watching